ERIC JOHNSON: My
name is Eric Johnson.
I'm a technical program manager.
I work on Google's Compute
Engine team up in Seattle,
and I thought I'd take
25 minutes of your time
today to talk a little
bit about Google Compute
Engine and open
source technologies.
Over this last year, as
you saw a previous session
and probably heard earlier
in the keynote this morning,
Compute Engine,
last year in 2013,
we went all the way
from invite only,
and then in I/O we
went to open sign-ups,
and then in December we went
to general availability.
So during that last
year also, I and several
of my colleagues
worked on contributing
code and documentation to
some popular open source
packages out there so
that if you're already
using those
technologies, you'd be
able to go ahead and use those
with Compute Engine as well.
But before I get into the
specifics of what we've
done there and some of the
projects we've contributed to,
I wanted to talk just
a little bit in general
about how Google
uses open source
and how we're effectively
built on top of open source.
It would be incredibly
challenging for Google
to exist as you know it
today without the foundations
of open source technology
and open standards.
We serve hundreds of millions of
users across Gmail and YouTube
and Maps, and none of that would
be possible without the ability
to be able to get in, kind
of roll up our sleeves,
and take a look at the
source code of some
of the technologies that
we use, make modifications
to that stuff, and
try and squeeze out
every ounce of performance
and scalability that we can.
So there's other alternatives
obviously, besides open source.
There's other closed source,
binary distributions or binary
packages out there
that you can use.
And so, I guess as
I think about sort
of maybe the differences between
the two, a good analogy to me
is painting.
So if you're a painter and you
start off with a blank canvas,
you have a couple of options.
You can choose what your
subject is going to be,
if you want to do a
portrait or a landscape,
you can choose between
different styles,
like abstract or
expressionism, impressionist,
and kind of the sky's the limit.
And as you go through, maybe
in working on your masterpiece,
I think one of the things
that's great about open source
software, which fits in
well with this analogy,
is the ability to be
able to sort of make
your own modifications to it.
So as I was going through
looking for pictures,
this one kind of
struck out at me.
And I was thinking as
Rembrandt's sitting here
painting this, he's
looking at this,
and he's like, you
know what, I've just
finished this great big
masterpiece, with the exception
that I think it's a
little bit too formal.
He originally had
a hat on everybody,
and he thought, all
right, well you know,
it's the 1600s, I'm going
to make it a little bit
more casual, kind of laid
back, so he just painted over
the hat on one of the
drapers pictured here.
So that's an example of being
able to take and start off
with whatever you want and
be able to make modifications
to it.
If I were to contrast that
with sort of the closed source
world and binary packages, you
can still create a painting,
but maybe your options are
a little bit more limited.
So maybe the paint-by-numbers is
a good way to think about that.
You are given a set of software
to build out your technology,
but you don't have
as much flexibility.
The design is already
chosen for you.
The color palette may
also be chosen for you.
Even the rearrangement of those
colors might be chosen for you.
And you don't have
the ability to be
able to go in and make
modifications to it.
So at the end of the day,
you can still finish up,
and you'll have a
decent painting,
but you just don't
have the flexibility
to kind of make it your own.
So how does Google use
open source software?
First and foremost,
we use Linux.
There's tens of
thousands of Googlers
employed all around the world,
and every one of those Googlers
runs-- well, a very
large number of them,
let's say-- run either
Linux or Unix derivative.
Unix had its sort of
roots in open source.
And all of us pretty
much use that.
There's utilities
installed on our laptops
and our workstations
that are all open source,
like sed and awk.
These are utilities that
engineers use every day.
All open source.
It enables us to do our jobs.
But not only do we run Linux on
our laptops and workstations,
but we also run it
in our data centers.
So every service that
you use at Google
is powered underneath
that by Linux.
Another way that
we use open source
is our development environment.
We use popular open source
programming languages
like Python or Go.
One of the things that
we do to get our job
done on a day-to-day basis,
we're working on source code
or making modifications to that.
We use open source integrated
development environments, IDEs.
We use open source text editors
for modifying source code.
We use open source
version control
to record changes that
we make to the system
and have that sort of history
of changes that we've made.
Compilers that we use to compile
the software, all of that
is open source as well.
But open source has
a lot of its roots,
and the ability to be able to
develop open source software
is based on open standards.
So these are standard
organizations
that have gotten
together and defined
in the open how certain
things should work,
the characteristics of it.
And then a lot of times
they'll create reference
implementations based
on those standards.
So if you think about
the presentation
that you're watching today,
whether you're here locally
or you're watching it
remote over YouTube,
there are a lot of
standards that are involved.
The original content
of this, this
is done in Google Apps in the
slides software, all of that
data actually lives someplace
in Google data center,
and it's being served
out over the network.
The network is defined
by open standards.
You have protocols
like TCP/IP and DNS
and HTTP in play,
all of that has
been defined as open standards.
Even the content on
the slides, the images
that you see, the content
of the slides itself,
that's being displayed via
HTML, CSS, JavaScript, again,
all things developed
off of open standards.
Even the text on the
screen, character encodings,
for Unicode or Ascii.
Again, open standards.
Even just displaying
this stuff uses
HDMI, DDI, VGA or
something like that.
Also, video encoding
over the internet,
H.264, again, all
open standards.
So Google clearly benefits
from open source software.
Like I said before,
everything that we've done
is built on top of
open source software
and we really wouldn't
exist in the way
that you know us today
without that foundation
in open source and
open standards.
So clearly we're
benefiting a lot,
but does that
benefit you at all?
Well, you know, one of the
key foundations of open source
is collaborating with others
and sharing those modifications
back and forth.
And Google does participate
in that as well.
Last year, Linux
Foundation, well
every year they publish a report
called "Who Writes Linux."
Last year in 2013,
Google moved up
into the top 10
corporate contributors
to the Linux kernel.
And you might think,
OK, Linux kernel,
Android runs Linux kernel.
It's probably all
Android development.
Well, in an article
published by Ars Tecnica,
they interviewed
Greg Kroah-Hartman,
who is the Linux
stable maintainer,
Linux kernel stable maintainer.
Greg was quick to point
out that Google is really
doing work all over the Kernel.
In fact, you heard if you saw
Joe, the previous session, Joe
Beda mentioned that we
contributed cgroups,
I think that was back
in 2007 and 2008,
and that's sort of the
underlying technology
behind containers and
some of the technology
that you see out there in the
open source world like Docker
today.
So not only are we
actively contributing
to the development
of the Linux Kernel,
Google also through
stipends and mentorship,
has a Google Summer
of Code Project.
What that is, we do pay
stipends to students
to contribute to
open source projects.
Google Summer of Code
I think we started
around 2005, and since that
time, through that program,
we've contributed over
50 million lines of code
to over 400 open
source projects.
So those are great examples
of Google contributed back
to existing projects.
Some of you are probably
already also aware
that Google does initiate a
lot of open source projects.
So to name a few, obviously
Android, everybody I'm sure
has heard of that.
Chromium, as a foundation
behind both Chrome Web browser,
as well as Chrome OS.
The Go programming language.
The V8 JavaScript
engine, which really
is the thing that makes
Node.js sort of under the hood,
makes Node.js possible.
So all of these are developed,
were initiated by Google
open source from the beginning.
They all have very
active contributions,
not only from Googlers, but
also from other external
corporations and even
external developers that
are interested in the technology
and want to participate in it.
So let's talk a little bit
about Compute Engine also.
Lots of announcements
today with Compute
Engine, and as we mentioned,
because it's a Google service,
it runs on top of
open source software.
So some of the open
source software
that we use to power
Compute Engine,
obviously it runs on
top of Linux servers
in our data centers, and we
use KVM as our virtualization
layer.
We provide a public
API, and that's
defined by open standards,
it's an HTTP REST API.
So there's nothing
sort of unique
about that, there's
nothing proprietary,
it's completely open
based off of standards.
Even the images
that you can launch,
the virtual machines
that you can spin up,
the operating systems
that we supply by default,
are Debian, CentOS, Red Hat
you saw, [? Rel, ?] and SUSE.
FreeBSD, you can even
spin up your own images
as you probably heard in
the previous presentation.
So again, open source
technology through and through.
Now we're kind of ready to
get into some of the work
that we've done for open
source projects that
are out there that do
support Compute Engine.
Kind of the best way I think
to probably start this off
is just sort of let's use the
Hello World of Compute Engine.
So, what I have up here is
13 lines of Python code,
and what this will do is
create a single virtual machine
in Compute Engine.
And this uses the open
source Python library.
It's an Apache Software
Foundation Project
called Libcloud.
It's a multi-cloud
library written in Python.
So you can use this with
other cloud providers as well.
So recognizing that there
might be users out there that
would be using another
provider that maybe would also
want to try Compute
Engine, we went through
and we contributed code and
documentation, sample scripts,
on how you, if you're
already using Libcloud
or an application
maybe that's even
built on top of the Libcloud,
can go in and basically make
some minor configuration
changes for authentication,
and, by and large, it
should probably just work.
You may have to make
some customizations there
in terms of the machine
size or the location,
but otherwise it's
the same concepts
that you would
get using Libcloud
with any other provider.
But maybe Python's
not your thing.
Maybe you're a Ruby developer.
Well fortunately, there is
another library out there
that's very similar to
Libcloud in that it works
with multiple
providers, and here I've
got a snippet of Ruby code,
which does effectively
the same thing.
In fact, the code
almost looks identical.
This fog is an open source
library all in Ruby,
and again, you can use that
with multiple cloud providers
as well.
And this is another example of
where Google contributed code
back over to the fog
open source community
to make sure that any fog
developers or applications that
are built using fog can now
also use Compute Engine.
So there's this other
language out there
called Java that's
proved very popular,
and there happens to be another
open source project very
similar to both
Libcloud and fog that
allows you to work with
multiple cloud providers.
And so here I've got
to 12 lines of code.
This one's a little bit
different in the sense
that this code snippet here, and
this is a jclouds sort of idiom
that they have templates
that you define,
where you set the node
attributes or the instance
attributes that
you want to create.
And so here I'm just
assuming that I'm
using the default in that
those are same values,
it's probably a single
core machine type,
and hopefully it's in a region
that's going to be close by.
But these are all attributes
that I could modify and change,
and then I can specify
my exact environment
that I want with jclouds.
So again, as I'd
mentioned, Google
had contributed to code with the
exception I think of jclouds.
We've kind of poked
at it a little bit
and offered some
help here and there,
but by and large, this was
done by the community itself.
So, I just showed you that you
can use-- programmatically,
you can create your own virtual
machines and spin those up.
And that's great, but now
you want to put them to work.
So the next thing
that you would do,
once you have your
instance up and running,
is you probably want to go ahead
and put your own software on it
or run a service on it.
And the way that
you would normally
do that, I guess just
sort of out of the box,
you'd probably SSH into that.
And since they're all open
source Linux distributions,
you'd use your package managers
to pull down your packages,
to pull you application
and get it configured.
And I think also you saw
in the previous talk,
if you saw that one, we talked
a little bit about snowflakes.
So you're going to
spend a lot of time
tuning and tweaking this
and getting it just right.
But then the next time
that you want to go and do
that, you have to
kind of remember, oh,
what were all those
packages I had to go?
Or how did I get around that
one particular dependency?
Oh yeah, that's right, I had to
compile that thing from source.
So there's a lot of things
that you want to make and turn
into sort of a
repeatable process.
There are a lot of open source
configuration management tools
out there that you can
use, and all of these now,
through code contributions by
Google, support Compute Engine.
So the two biggest
ones that you probably
have heard of, Puppet
and Chef, but then
there's also newer ones
that are coming out,
SaltStack and Ansible.
And again, all of these
support Compute Engine.
So tying back into the
previous conversation
about getting away from
snowflakes, all of these tools
allow you to create a
configuration that represents
the desired state of
your server or servers,
your virtual machines
in the cloud.
It's like a declarative syntax.
It doesn't tell
really how a machine
should get itself configured.
You just say, here are the
services I want, the packages I
want, the users
that are created,
file permissions,
anything that you
can think of that
you would normally
do through just manual
one-off commands,
you can capture in a
configuration file.
Those configuration
files can be versioned,
so you can track
changes to that stuff,
if you make a mistake
you can roll it back.
They all strive
to be idempotent,
so you can rerun the same
command over and over again
and tune and tweak it
and run the same command,
and it will only install
things that have changed.
It's a great way to try and
tune and get your environment
set up just the way you like.
And as I mentioned,
Google contributed a lot
to the development of Compute
Engine support into these.
There's a lot of other open
source packages out there
and here's some of
the other popular ones
that we've come across.
In some cases, Google
has contributed either
directly to the project,
or through code, or just
through documentation.
Like Docker, I think for
instance, one of our developer
advocates put together a nice
clean set of instructions,
it's like 10 lines of code to
get up and running with that.
CoreOS has an image that you
can put into your project,
and you can run the CoreOS image
right inside of Compute Engine.
Vagrant is another tool that
you can use to kind of quickly
spin up a development
environment,
and that works with
Compute Engine.
And Packer is
another project that
allows you to sort of
bundle up your image
and get it customized the way
you want and then reuse that.
So let's flip over to a demo.
So we should have a terminal
come up here in a second.
Let me just cat out this file.
So this is very similar
to the little Hello World
example in Python that
I showed you before.
The only couple differences
here to call out,
obviously lines five, six, and
seven have my authentication
credentials in it
for my project,
but one of the other
differences here is on line 11,
I'm going to use a
wrapping function
that we added to Libcloud,
which allows you to create
multiple virtual machines
with a single method call.
So rather than
having to re-execute
the single create node
inside of a while loop,
we sort of do all
of that for you.
And let's see, what else.
Oh-- I've got it hard
coded in there on line 14
that we want to create
100 virtual machines.
And then on line
16, what we'll do
is we'll print out--
that will return
an array of created
virtual machines.
And then so on
line 16, I'm going
to print out sort of
the length of that list,
and hopefully that
comes out to be 100.
And then how long did that take.
Let's just go
ahead and run this.
So let's call this Hello
World Times 100, I guess.
So, I'll flip over to the
developer console here,
and you can see this is the
demo virtual machine that I
was on when I executed
that command just now.
So we should start to see
a couple instances spin up.
OK, so flipping over
to the Disks tab,
our virtual machines now
use persistent disks.
That's your only
option right now.
There is no ephemeral
disk or scratch disk.
So what this has done
is it's created the 100
persistent disks.
Each is 10 gigs
in size, and each
has the Debian image
loaded on them.
And then we also have
the 100 instances
that are being created.
And so each of those
instances is matched.
I should have pointed this
out in the sample code,
but I give it a name
prefix of LC for Libcloud,
and then it just depends
on an auto incrementing
integer for each
instance it creates.
And then that also matches the
name of the persistent disk,
and so then that's what
it uses as its boot disk.
One thing I'd like to point
out as you're getting up
to speed with Compute Engine
and you want to learn our API,
there's a couple things.
So what I did here
is I drilled down
into just one of these
instances, in this case LC001,
and I'm scrolling
down, and I'm looking
at some of the attributes on it.
But down here at
the bottom, we have
a couple hyperlinks
that you can click on,
and this will show
you the exact REST
API that defines this instance.
So that's a great
way to learn the API.
And then there's
also Compute Engine
provides a command line
utility called gcutil, which
is part of G Cloud, and this
gives you the exact SSH command
that you can just cut and paste
SSH directly into that machine.
So I wanted to call that out
because that's a great way
to get up and running
with Compute Engine.
Just kind of quickly drilling
through some of this stuff.
Snapshots, from a
persistent disk,
you can create a
snapshot off of that.
And snapshots are
stored globally,
so this is a great way for
you to replicate data around.
You can create your instance,
customize it the way you want,
and then take a snapshot
of that persistent disk,
and then bring up another
persistent disk, let's
say in Europe, and an
instance based off of that,
and you've just replicated
your instance over there.
So let's go back to
the instance list.
And if we scroll
all the way down,
hopefully we'll see down
to 99, so let's find out
how long did it take us to
create 100 virtual machines.
So 100 in 1 minute
and 27 seconds.
And these, again, they're
all Debian images.
You can SSH into
any one of these,
and we had 100% success
in less than two minutes.
So if we can flip back
to the slides, please.
So what's next?
So there's a lot of things
that came out today.
So as we've been working
to contribute code
back to the open
source community
for supporting
Compute Engine, we're
always iterating on things.
We're always changing things.
And it's a difficult job to
kind of keep up with that.
And it's a small group
of us within Google
that are kind of contributing
some of our part-time work
to this stuff.
And in the spirit
of open source,
we'd love to
collaborate with you.
You can find me on
GitHub @erjohnso.
And if you have a project
that is an open source
project out there, and
you'd like us to see,
maybe kind of help you out
either with some guidance
or even some code
or documentation,
feel free to do an
@mention on your project
and kind of bring
it to my attention.
And if it's not something
that I can personally take on,
there's a lot of people
that work at Google,
and I might be able to find
somebody that can help you.
I'd also like to point
out we have a GitHub
organization called
Google Cloud Platform
and there are a lot of great
repositories set up there that
are samples, applications,
demos, that type of thing
across all of the Google
Cloud Platform services.
So I really encourage you
to check that stuff out,
and I'd like to thank
you for your time.